PETE LEPAGE: Well, welcome
everybody.
My name's Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
here at Google.
And with me today, we've got a
very special group of people
to talk about Movi.Kanti.Revo,
the new Chrome experiment in
conjunction with the team
at Cirque du Soleil.
With me, I've got a Nicole
McDonald, who was the creative
director on the project and
Gillian Ferrabee, who is a
creative director at
Cirque du Soleil.
Nicole, why don't you introduce
yourself first,
because you're up on screen.
And then we'll have Gillian
introduce herself.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Hi, I'm
Nicole McDonald.
It's a pleasure to
be with you.
I'm a creative director and
director specializing in
interactive directing.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Cool.
And Gillian, do you want
to introduce yourself?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Yeah hi,
I'm Gillian Ferrabee.
I'm the creative director
at Cirque du Soleil.
My title is creative director
of images and special
projects, which is mostly
anything to do with TV, film,
and new media.
And this project would fall
under special projects.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
All right, well, cool.
So today, while we've got some
of these things going on, if
you guys have questions, things
that you want to ask of
folks, we've got a place where
you can ask questions at
goo.gl/5iDjh.
The URL is there on screen.
So if you have questions, things
that you want to know a
little bit more about, feel
free to go and post your
questions there.
And we'll take your questions
as we get towards the end of
the session.
So with that, I want to take it
over to Nicole to start and
say, Nicole, when you started
thinking about this project,
where did your initial
inspiration
come from for this?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, we
actually really researched
Cirque du Soleil, and the
brand, and also the live
shows, and we tried to figure
out where to bring the live
show into an interactive
space.
And one of the inspirations
was magic.
Magic is something that draws us
in, [INAUDIBLE] to the eye.
It's visceral.
There's emotion behind it, and
that's where we, kind of-- we
thought about magic.
Magic [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: So what about the
magic of Cirque du Soleil sort
of brought you to
that experience?
What were some of the things
that you thought about that
would translate well
to the web?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, one of
the things that I think Cirque
du Soleil does extremely,
extremely well is, it kind of
is a feast of sense.
It's so beautiful, there's so
many colors, there's so many
things going on.
It's just hyper,
hyper gorgeous.
[INAUDIBLE]
points, well, one of the points
that we wanted to be
careful of was that in a live
experience, we feel connected
in ways that we don't when
we sit behind a computer.
And so one of our wants was to
really figure out how we could
get closer to the action and
experience it, maybe, in that
same way we would with
a live event.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And Gillian, for you, as you
started to look at this
project and start thinking about
this project, where did
the inspiration come
from for you?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I think for
us, the first meetings we had,
the two things that came up as
themes in terms of bringing
Cirque du Soleil to the world
of the web was curiosity is
something that Cirque
creates for their
audience as a way to engage.
So as Nicole said, it's magical,
and you want to
understand what's behind that
magic or where that magic is
going to take you.
So that idea of still being
able stretch people's
imagination and initiate
curiosity, which would give
someone the desire, then, to
move forward and into the
experience, in the sense
of interactivity.
And the other thing that came
up for us is adventure.
Because the web gives this sense
that you can access the
whole world.
What's the edge of the map?
How far can you go?
And how wide can you reach?
So [INAUDIBLE] came up with
curiosity, in the sense of
magic, and adventure.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool I think, for
me, one of the really amazing
things about the web
is that we are
always pushing it forward.
Or we're always trying
to push it forward.
And that's certainly one of the
main components of Chrome
experiments is, like, we can
take the web here, and what we
do to push it to that
really neat thing?
And how do we make it do
something it's never seen
somebody do before?
Nicole, when you started working
on this, how did the
technology affect your
inspiration?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, it's
actually going back to the
live shows.
Even though you're not
necessarily interacting, it is
still a 3D experience.
And one of the things that I
really wanted was to have it
be engaging in a
3D experience.
And so that's where we came up
with the idea that we were
using a 2D world
in a 3D space.
And so I think the technology
allowed us to really create a
layered environment.
And that, I think, started to
snowball into, how do you
create a layered environment?
What does it do?
How does it react?
Why does react?
And I think that's a good
question is, why?
Why use technology?
And it's really to tell
more of a story.
PETE LEPAGE: So you see
technology being a good way to
tell a better story and engage
with people in storytelling
and more dynamic experiences?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, from
an artistic level, I think
technology is a paintbrush,
right?
So it's in size.
You can either use a fat
one, or you use a
smaller one for details.
I think that technology is
also just a way-- it's an
outlet to communicate ideas.
And the exciting thing about
it is, like you said, it's
never been done before.
But also, we can pull in people
to dream in ways that
they haven't before.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
This is a question for
both of you guys.
Before you came to the web, or
before you started playing
with technology, what is your
creative experiences based on?
Did it come from painting,
drawing, or did it always
really exist around the web?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Gillian?
[LAUGHS].
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Wow.
Well, my personal history
goes way back.
I've been performing and making
art since as long as I
can remember.
My mother's a designer and an
artist and an educator.
But for me, it's been
mostly live and some
drawing, music, singing.
But the primary has been live
audience, traditional and
nontraditional stage.
PETE LEPAGE: OK
NICOLE MCDONALD: And for me,
my background has been
everything.
You know, wit Christmas every
year, I got a new art kit.
I was constantly a
little artist.
I started, actually, in college
as a performance and
filmmaking and painting.
[LAUGHS].
And then I immediately, after
college, went into games.
And I painted sets for games.
And that started my interest
in interactive.
And so I took this fine
art world and
started making it digital.
I was really quite lucky.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Gillian, when Nicole and the
crew first sat down with you
guys and said, hey, here's this
really cool experience
that we're thinking about doing,
and showed some of
their inspiration and mood
boards, what did you think of
what they were showing and where
they were going with
some of these things?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Well, the
first thing that was, I think,
exceptional and almost magical,
really, to use the
word, was that we had prepared
a mood board, and there was
actually one image that we both
had chosen for our mood
board, of all that's possible
to find on the net.
So that was kind of
mind blowing.
When they presented their mood
board, we looked at each
other, like, we didn't give
that to them, did we?
No, we haven't talked
to each other.
So there was an immediate
complicity and common vision
that was obvious from that and
from a few other things.
And the other thing, from the
Cirque's point of view, that
was a strong indicator was--
I can't remember, I think was
Nicole, but somebody brought
up the idea of the screen, what
you might call the fourth
wall, and how to playfully
interact with your audience.
Like now, even, this is live,
we're talking-- how do you
interact through this new
form of communicator?
And that was something we were
definitely curious about.
So those were the two things
that pretty much nailed it.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Nicole, what were your feelings
on those first couple
of meetings, when you sat down
and said, this is what we're
thinking, going from a really
web and creative background to
a company who's all
about doing live,
in-person kind of stuff?
NICOLE MCDONALD: It was super,
super exciting, obviously, I
mean, I kind of a dream
come true, really.
To work with such a creative,
imaginative, really
responsible company, that's
kind of rare.
But I think the challenge of
it all was thrilling, to
really kind of crack open the
nut a little bit and be able
to do take a step into a
direction of interactive
performing is super exciting.
PETE LEPAGE: So as you started
working on some of this stuff
and sort of took the technology
with your vision,
how did the technology change
the way that you saw the
vision being done as you were
working through the project?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, I think
I'm a developer's worst
nightmare in that [INAUDIBLE],
because I think I know enough
of what technology can do, I
know where we can push it.
I think that one of the
challenges for us, from a
development standpoint was,
could we get things in time?
Could different technologies be
available at that moment?
I think that was our
biggest challenge.
PETE LEPAGE: So whether and
when technology came on,
whether you had access to it?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, and I
think that usually the process
of how I work in an interactive
space is, we
dream, and then we kind
of dial it back.
And then we become detectives
and solve problems, which is,
I think, the best-case
scenario.
Solving problems means we move
forward, which is [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Were there any
problems that you were really
proud of having solved with this
project, technology-wise,
creativity-wise?
NICOLE MCDONALD: That's a
really good question.
I think you'll notice that
there's an incredible amount
of layered sprites and divs,
figuring out what a system
could handle.
And you dream big and so you
have, like, seven videos
playing, and all these
animations, and then there are
all these huge files.
And then really figuring
out, OK, now we have--
it's not moving on a computer.
So nobody can watch it.
It looks great, but
nobody can see it.
Really figuring out what
that wait was.
So how do we turn this down, but
still, how do we maintain
our vision?
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
NICOLE MCDONALD: That was
definitely a big challenge.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
What was it like going through
the process of saying, OK, so
we've got our idea here.
What did the workflow look like,
to say, all right, so
here's our idea, after those
first meetings with Cirque, to
then go and get to that
final project?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, we took
some time and wrote the story.
That was super fun, just
to tell the narrative.
And then once we had the
narrative, we actually made it
a functioning animatic And then
from the animatic, it
kind of gave us the answer of
flow and also an asset list,
which was super important.
PETE LEPAGE: For each of the
different scenes, yeah.
NICOLE MCDONALD: And
then we shot it.
And then at the shoot, we were
able to kind of pull in video
live and be able to see how it
moved and whether or not our
horizon line was correct, or
overshooting it, or even just
if it was a worthwhile
experience.
And then from there on,
it was just, go.
PETE LEPAGE: And Gillian, how
did you see, and how did your
team work with Nicole to really
take that vision from
beginning to end?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I think the
main thing was keeping in
touch all along the way so that
everybody had a sense of
what was happening, what
it looked like.
Did it match what we wanted
and imagined?
I can't think of any specific
obstacle, but I know that we
hit a bunch.
And Nicole probably
remembers this.
We would always say, well,
that's because something else
even better's going to
show up, which it
actually did, often.
The part that was most
interesting, for us, I would
say, was the actual shoot and
watching how the artists,
themselves, how Nicole was able
to translate to them what
their work was going to look
like in the final product.
Because a live performer knows,
they're onstage when
it's happening.
So what they give comes
from that knowledge.
And so Nicole was able to inform
them the context that
they were performing in, what
it would look like, and then
they were able to play and adapt
with that, which was
exciting for us to see that.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, and
I think that's where the
animatic played an incredible
role, and also being able to
input stuff immediately live.
In a green screen environment,
it's cold.
There's no connection.
And I think that was super
exciting that we were able to
show the artists where they were
in the space and really
let them have that world and
take over that world.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, actually, I
just got some of the green
screen video set up so that we
can see have a quick peek at
that, I think.
Let me see if I can get
that running here.
There we go.
So we've got some picture in
picture going so that folks
can see what's going on there.
So this was the scene where
our guide jumps
backwards off the log.
And you can see her there
on that blue screen.
Nicole, as we run through that,
what was your process of
thinking through how to do these
things, because you see
just this blue screen.
And the artist has really no
idea, we have really no idea,
until we see what's going
on, what to expect.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, what we
tried to do is to have some
key frames to show the artist
where they were in the space,
and also for us to be able
to plan appropriately.
This is an A-camera.
We don't have a B-camera to cut
to, so the entire scene is
first person POV.
So we really needed to make sure
that there was a thread
throughout-- like a breadcrumb
trail continuous, throughout
the experience.
And with these frames, we were
also able to build out the 3D
experience, and then immediately
key the video and
put them into an environment
to help the artist see what
space they were working
in, and to--
what was the first film of Star
Wars that came out, where
they used blue screen
everywhere?
PETE LEPAGE: The remakes,
or the--
NICOLE MCDONALD: The new ones.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, yes.
NICOLE MCDONALD: I just remember
how cold that was.
There was no connection.
And there was just
these two people
speaking to one another.
We were joking and saying, we
do not want to create that.
PETE LEPAGE: Gillian, for you
guys, was this the first big
web project that you guys had
worked on at Cirque du Soleil?
Or how had you guys worked
with the web before?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: It was
the first creative
project, I would say.
Obviously Cirque has done lots
of marketing, and the company
website, and other, more
traditional, transitions to
the web, doing things that
people were doing anyway,
before the web, but in
a different way.
But this was the actual--
the content was created
for this project, and
it was fully creative.
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Were you somewhat
skeptical at the beginning, or
did you think that we would
be able to create such an
immersive, Cirque-like
experience right off the bat?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I'm a highly
optimistic person, so I wasn't
skeptical, because I
almost never am.
But I would say there
were definitely lots
of people who were.
And the minute we met Nicole and
their team, that went out
the window.
Their enthusiasm--
and maybe they were as highly
optimistic, but they were the
experts, and they seemed really
excited that it was possible.
So that schooled us
pretty quickly.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
awesome, yeah.
How would you describe the
difference between working
with a web experience and
working with a live show,
starting something like that?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Wow, that's
a good question.
It's completely different,
because, from the beginning,
your framework is
not a theater.
It's not an audience.
It's a platform, in a way.
It's a tool.
But there's much more unknown,
which can be exciting, except
that, when you're doing a show,
the parameters are very
concrete and practical.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
GILLIAN FERRABEE:
Go ahead Nicole?
NICOLE MCDONALD: I was just
going to say, I think it's
practical because it's known.
Because we haven't defined the
process of interactive--
there is no cookie cutter
process, necessarily.
I think that that's the exciting
and the scary part.
GILLIAN FERRABEE:
It's definitely
exciting for Cirque.
And the first question we asked
ourselves is, what are
all the things that we can't do
in a live show because of
the parameters of time, or the
weight of something, or the
feasibility, visually?
The suspension of disbelief is
completely different live.
So it's a very exciting
terrain.
I mean, Cirque has always been
interested in the unknown, as
Nicole said.
PETE LEPAGE: So what were some
of the things that, right off
the bat, when you said, what are
the things we can't do a
live show, what were some of the
things that you said, we
can't do, could we do
these on the web?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: The first
thing that comes up is, in the
web, you have, to some
degree more say how
the story is told.
Because live, you don't
know where the
person's going to look.
Which Cirque is a real master
of giving people lots of
things to look at and, in a way,
guiding their attention.
So that's different.
On the web, it gives more
of a traditional
storytelling process.
And the other thing
is practical--
like, to get something onto
stage takes time.
And to get it off takes time.
And when you're shooting, you
can do that before you turn
the camera on for however
long it takes.
So that's a very practical and
very creative examples.
PETE LEPAGE: Were there any
things in the Movi.Kanti.Revo
experience that you pushed
to have them try
some of those things?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Nothing
comes to mind because my
experience is that Nicole
and [INAUDIBLE]
surprised us over and over.
We didn't have time
to catch up.
NICOLE MCDONALD: From our
perspective, I think it was
about, really, how to challenge
this experience of
intimate, a one-on-one
experience, whereas in the
theater, there's many, many
people around you.
So how do I engage somebody in
the one-on-one experience?
And then also perspective--
we can gauge perspective
behind a computer.
In a theater, you're
in a seat.
[INAUDIBLE]
that Cirque does an amazing
job doing many shows, like
you're moving around the space
as much as they're moving
around you.
But I think that's a really
super interesting thing for
how to translate live experience
in the future is,
it's a virtual theater seat.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah actually,
that's a perfect segue into
the next question I have, which
is, what do you think
that the web brings to
experiences that you can't do
in a live show?
And where do you see that going
and changing the way
some, not just Cirque shows, but
in all live entertainment
changes in the future?
NICOLE MCDONALD: That's
a very good--
I mean, I don't really think we
know quite yet until we do.
Because I think the wonderful
part of about doing stories
interactively is that every
single time, we find out
something new about a way to
engage somebody differently.
And that's, I think, the part
of the process that is the
most challenging, because
it's almost like--
and I think this is why my
developers kind of hate me
sometimes-- not hate me,
but obviously, raise
their fist to me--
is because I think I'm
constantly using technology in
ways that it's not supposed
to be used.
And that's how we
move forward.
That's how we push the lines.
PETE LEPAGE: I think one of the
things that really excites
me with the web is, it's
not always about--
the technology is not supposed
to used this way.
It's that as browser vendors, or
as the people who make the
specifications develop stuff,
they say, hey, we think it's
going to get used this way.
But then creative, brilliant
people like you guys come in
and say, oh, hey, if I
do this and this, I
can get this to happen.
And suddenly you get something
that's never really been seen
or done before.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, it's
like using a hammer for
something else other
than nailing.
If there's a tool available,
then it can kind of push us
into ways that we don't
reveal yet.
GILLIAN FERRABEE: One other
thing that comes to mind from
a live [? performance ?]
point of view is there is a
different kind of intimacy.
As Nicole was saying, you can
move the camera into places
that you can't always
see from your seat.
And then the other thing that's
way out there is the
web provides a different kind
of live, which is--
for instance, in the way that
if you're using an app,
sometimes you can see who else
is using it at that moment.
There's a collective
participation over time and
space that you never have with
the limitations of 1,200
people from 8:00 to 10:30 or any
form of live experience.
There's that potential for
a different kind of live.
NICOLE MCDONALD: And a very
new and exciting unity.
There's people that are coming
together that would never have
the opportunity to
come together.
It's incredibly exciting.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, let's talk about the
workflow, a little bit, of
taking some of the actual
practical things and putting
them onto the web into some
of those experiences.
So Nicole, as you started going
through and saying, OK,
this is what I want some of
these scenes to look like, how
did you say--
for example, the tree
of life scene--
how did you translate that from
being something in your
head to being something very,
like, touch, like, I can go
and see that, I can
move around?
NICOLE MCDONALD: I think it's
that this is about sketching.
We sketched the tree out.
I kind of [? drew ?] the layout,
originally, handed it
to some very talented artists,
who painted it.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, when you say
painted it, because we've got
a lot of different types of
folks who are watching this--
some may be a little bit more
like me, who are more
developer oriented.
And for me, I know how to
write some angle bracket
markup-y like stuff, but
anything more than that, I
need your help.
So what's painting it mean, and
how do you go about that?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Well, I really
wanted the experience
to be very set designed, but
also touched by humans.
So we actually literally
created paintbrushes in
Photoshop, and if you zoom into
some of the [INAUDIBLE]
the pieces, you'll actually see
the actual paint brushes
of the artist that digitally
painted, in Photoshop, each of
the elements that we created.
Because we wanted it to feel,
actually, a bit of Renaissance
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
I think you broke up there at
the last little second, but I
think you were saying
Renaissance paintings, and
each one was hand drawn.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah,
I'm breaking up.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, well,
hopefully this will clear up
here in a second.
So from the point where you
started taking each thing, and
turned each painting--
designed each scene in
Photoshop, where did it go
from there?
So you've got this great PSD
file that's potentially pretty
huge, and you can't just hand
that over to a developer.
So what happened next?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Then we
had this huge PSD, and
we pulled it apart.
Can you hear me, OK?
PETE LEPAGE: I can now.
All right, looks like we've
lost you here for a sec.
Let's see, Gillian, why don't
we pop over to you for a sec
and give it a sec for
Nicole's network
connection to come back.
What was your favorite scene
in this project?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Wow.
I sincerely love them all
for different reasons.
They have different energies
and different flavor.
I mean, the tree of life
was the one that
surprised me the most--
how moving it was, how effective
and how moving, when
he floats up at the end,
I was completely
surprised the first time.
And then I really loved when the
user arrives at the fork
in the road in the forest,
because it was just
delightful.
The delight of this little
tricycle coming and then the
clown, and how that all works
so beautifully, the same way
it would've onstage, those are
the ones that I remember at
this moment the most.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool Nicole,
do we have you back?
No, looks like no Nicole yet.
All right, well, I've got to
say, I think my favorite scene
was tree of life, as well.
There was just something
absolutely beautiful about it
that really said--
between the growth of
everything, between the way
that you can go in and see all
of the different things
interacting and moving together,
it's just such a
beautiful thing.
And in some ways, I think
that scene is kind of
a little bit sad.
But it's also just so--
I feel like, it's a great big
circle, which is kind of fun,
something that you don't
typically see around
in stuff like that.
All right, it looks like
we've got Nicole back.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Sorry guys.
PETE LEPAGE: That's OK.
And it looks beautifully nice
and sunny there now.
I'm jealous.
Cool.
Well, Nicole, we were talking
about taking that gigantic PSD
and turning it into something
that, as a developer, I could
go do something with.
Do you want to talk about
that a little bit more?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Sure.
So the PSD, one of things,
[INAUDIBLE] that we had to
kind of creative a layered PSD
that was appropriate for the
space in which we were
putting it in.
So in other words, if we had
some trees, if there's trees
behind them, those trees behind
had to be painted.
So in Photoshop, this huge,
layered file then got cut into
transparent [INAUDIBLE]
and optimized.
And then we brought them into
the 3D space in HTML5.
And that was kind of it.
It was pretty long term in the
effort it took it to create,
but once it was created,
it was executed fast.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
And just as a reminder for those
folks who are watching
live right now, we do have a
place where you can go ask
questions if you have questions
for Gillian or Nicole.
You can post your questions
there, and we'll take some of
those as we get towards the
end of the session.
But the URL is up on
screen right now.
Nicole, I had asked Gillian what
her favorite scene was.
What's your favorite scene
in the experience?
NICOLE MCDONALD: That's
a good question.
I think probably, the
tree of life.
I think the barge performance,
I think, is really lovely.
PETE LEPAGE: Which one was the
barge performance again?
NICOLE MCDONALD: The one with
the clown pulling the house,
and then the girls coming out
and dancing and performing.
I loved the fork in the road.
I like a lot of them.
PETE LEPAGE: Which one do you
think you're most proud of?
NICOLE MCDONALD: I think
the tree of life.
I feel like that was the
closest to what I had
envisioned.
The clown is just--
the fool in love is
so beautiful.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah it's pretty
pretty is slightly awkward to
say, but very true.
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I think what
people love about that is that
the poetry translates.
It's a very poetic
representation of something.
And everyone I've spoken
to got it.
They got the metaphor, and they
understood and were very
moved at the end,
when he floats.
So that's what struck me, is
how, again, this concept of
the web, and a screen, and how
such a depth of human poetry
can translate.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah.
That was for my grandfather,
actually.
He's very connected
with family.
He's just madly in
love with family.
So I thought that was a nice
homage to my grandfather.
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Wow.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow, that's
kind of neat.
Gillian, how do think Cirque's
going to approach the web
differently because of this
experiment and the way that
people have been responding
to it?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: How are we
going to respond differently?
We're just really excited.
It was a delight from
beginning to
end, the whole process.
And people have responded
beyond our expectations,
in-house and everybody
outside.
So that only creates the
appetite to continue.
That's basically what--in the
big picture, there's lots of
excitement around it and lots of
interest and ideas and just
general excitement.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
really cool.
And it's so neat to see this
kind of stuff really whetting
the appetite.
One of the things that I hope
comes out of this and other
Chrome experiments is really to
get other developers, other
creatives excited, that they
can go do things on the web
that they've never seen
done before, right?
We've never seen a 3D world like
this built where you can
change the angles and interact
with it in such different and
neat ways until now.
And this really has said,
hey, look, we can
do something neat.
Why don't you go
try something?
In terms of the workflow, as you
started building this, to
jump back to that kind of stuff,
Gillian, how did you
see the workflow happening in
terms of working with a
company who wasn't necessarily
Cirque developers, and Cirque
designers, and Cirque people?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Well again,
it was all new,
I think, for us.
I don't know for
Nicole's team.
I would say Nicole's experience
with a diverse
background, having done film,
having done live performance,
meant that she knew how
to speak to us.
I think that facilitated
a lot.
And it was really the ongoing
sharing of just where
everybody was at, and a lot
of visual referencing.
And then the big chunk
was the actual
shoot itself, obviously.
That was, I would say, the peak
of the collaborative part
on a day-to-day basis.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, we're getting a little
bit close to the end.
I want to take a look at some
of the questions that we've
got from some folks who are
posting their questions.
So one of the questions that
we've got is, where do you
think the web is going to be
with Cirque in 10 years?
And this is, I guess, for both
of you, because I think this
kind of interesting for both
of you guys to take.
And I'm going to tack on a
little bit of an extra
sentence on there--
not just Cirque, but
performances and art in general.
NICOLE MCDONALD: My hope is that
it's an experience that
we're participants in.
I think that we've come close
to being able to be
engaged on the web.
I would love to see performance,
especially on the
web, become about me feeling
connected in ways that I
haven't before.
And whether that's with touch
and call and response, meaning
if I touch somebody, do they
have goosebumps, suddenly?
If I touch them hard,
do they get bruised?
I think that's where
we're going.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So new interactions and better
ways to touch the audience.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, and
the audience is suddenly
participants.
And it's kind of dictated by
their own personal experience
and desire.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Gillian, what are
your thoughts?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I mean, 10
years is a long way, in terms
of technology, to ever imagine
what's going to have happened.
I think the two most exciting
things-- the first is, kind of
what Nicole was saying, but
I would say around the
refinement and sophistication of
kinesthetic interactivity.
So that's something that Cirque
thinks about a lot,
which would allow for the user,
which is what we call
the name for the person now,
whereas we had a conversation
about it recently where, it
could go so fast, or there
could be so many dimensions that
it's not longer the user
and the web, but there's going
to be a whole sense of
possibilities of the user being
part of the art, and
influencing the art, and then
the art responding to that,
and there being so many
possibilities in
that that it really--
the line becomes more
and more blurred.
And then the other one is, I
think Nicole mentioned it
earlier, what the web provides
in terms of the opportunity
for people to find each other
that have more and more
specific things in common, and
how that's going to affect
art, per se.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
an interesting idea.
So one of the questions that I
had, that I wanted to sort of
continue on with some of the
things we were talking about
earlier, is, how do you guys
want to see technology change
in the near term, so like in the
next couple of months, to
make these experiences better
or more interactive?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Technology
physically?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Alpha channel
video in WebM.
PETE LEPAGE: Why don't you talk
a little bit about why
you want that?
Because I know that was
something we were trying to
get in, and unfortunately
we didn't get it in
in time into Chrome.
It's coming soon
but not quite.
NICOLE MCDONALD: It's actually
something I've wanted, about,
for two years now.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Because you
have more control of changing
the way a video or
an experience is.
Let me think for a second.
So if I have an alpha channel
video, and my videos are on
rails, meaning I have a
narrative that is moving from
A to B, I have no ability to
switch those rails and have
the content or narrative
change quickly.
With alpha channel video, we can
have a much more reactive
environment for the user in
the narrative meaning.
And I have hope that that's
something that we have a
little bit more control over in
the future, is that we can
kind of change the narrative on
the fly, depending on what
user is reactive to.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah and in
Movi.Kanti.Revo we kind of did
that at one point, where there's
the fork in the road
scene where the user can choose
which direction to go.
But it's a very limited amount
of changing on the fly.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Right, and if
you had a WebM alpha, the
possibilities of A or B, becomes
A to Z, which, I think
would be exciting.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And Gillian, what about you?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I don't
have the same tech
knowledge of lingo.
But two things that come to mind
for me, it's simply that
people think about interactivity
as a full-bodied
experience.
Obviously, being a dancer from
Cirque, that's the first thing
that comes to mind.
Anything to facilitate, and
encourage, and play with
people using their whole body,
not just hands and eyes.
And the other thing is the
context and the environment.
I love the idea of anything
where the screen
is somewhere different.
It's on the street, it's on the
floor, the screen comes to
me more in my world than
just at my computer.
I think that as a 3D dancer
person, that's what I'm
looking for.
PETE LEPAGE: I think that's a
really powerful piece, that we
are interacting with more and
more screens every day,
whether you're talking about
your smartphone, whether
you're talking about your
laptop, your desktop, maybe
it's a tablet that you're
walking around with.
There are just so many different
screens that
we have access to.
And seeing these experiences
on more and more of these
scenes, I think, is phenomenally
powerful and a
really cool, fun thing to
see the web change.
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I think It
opens up the possibility for
surprise, which is one of the
best things in life and also
neat in that we all all live
in worlds, often, that are
very busy, and very repetitive,
and where we have
physical routines in
our life every day.
So the idea that a screen can
play the part of a magical
moment, the way flash mobs work,
dance mobs, where at the
beginning, you're going to work,
and you're going through
central station as you do every
morning, and then, ahh,
people start dancing.
So how can screens or the
capacity for screens to be in
new places begin to
provide that?
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, and how
do we show something new, and
exciting, and different to
people who wouldn't have
access to new and
exciting things?
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, so I want to wrap up with
one question for both of
you guys to answer.
And it's really about, if you
could say to other designers
and creative folks, after having
worked through this
project, what would
you say to them?
How would you encourage them
to go and play with this?
Or what would you say?
NICOLE MCDONALD: To--
playing with Movi?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
NICOLE MCDONALD: I would love
for people to go and see it,
and experience it, and be
excited by it, but also to
help us move forward
with technology.
And how would they do
it differently?
What would they do to make the
story have more depth or add
more creativity to it?
And then go do it so that we
kind of keep leapfrogging and
progressing, and inspiring
each other.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And Gillian, what are your
thoughts on that?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: My thoughts
are to encourage other
physically creative people--
so that would mean anyone
whose art form is
their own body--
to being playing with people
whose art form is technology.
Because I was so surprised,
with this project, how
visceral my response to the
artists was, how much I could
really feel them, and their
personalities, and their
charisma, and what they
were emanating.
So I think that's really
encouraging for people who are
physical performers, to know
that when you partner with the
right artist of technology,
they're as excited as you to
have that happen.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So we just actually had one
question pop in on the
question list that I
think is actually
a really neat question.
And the answer I'll give
immediately is, not right now,
but I'm curious what
you guys think.
Is there any possibility of
Movi.Kanti.Revo being
implemented on Google Glass and
this virtual space being
overlaid in the real world?
How do you guys see that
actually happening?
Because--
NICOLE MCDONALD: [INAUDIBLE].
We have actually talked
about it.
And we have some ideas on how to
make this almost, kind of,
be an interactive flash mob.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh neat.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Yeah, we
potentially could be putting
it in places that surprise
us and draw us in.
PETE LEPAGE: Gillian, are you
familiar with Google Glass?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: No.
PETE LEPAGE: Google Glass is
a project that Google has
started working on.
It's a research project for the
most part right now, but
effectively what it is is it's
a pair of glasses that you
wear that have a little
display right here.
And you can interact with
it in all kinds
of different ways.
So the video that they showed
was showing being able to get
maps, but being able to send
messages, call people, talk to
people, because you have that
display right there in your
field of view, or maybe it's a
little bit above, or something
to that effect.
But you've always got that
technology right
there around you.
GILLIAN FERRABEE: I
had heard of it.
I didn't know what
it was called.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, so
for something like
Movi.Kanti.Revo, how do you see
that, maybe, playing into
something like this?
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Well, what
comes to mind first is the
obvious one, of the characters
being a part of your daily
life, and making even more
practical uses playful.
So if it's a map, as happened in
the forest, that they could
playfully feed you
the information.
And the other thing that
comes to mind is just--
my memory is that, in our brain,
80% of our receptors
are visual, and it affects our
whole body and our brains in
ways that we're just
learning about now.
So I think there's possibilities
beyond that that
the biological science
is going to
meet us on that front.
Who knows what it would do to
your body to think you were in
a forest when you
are in a city.
And if the forest is peopled
with fun, magical people,
would your whole body relax?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
It would be interesting to take
that same technology and
concept and go the other way.
So put those on people at a
Cirque show, where you can
take the just amazing magic of
a Cirque show and augment it
even more by providing things
that change for each person.
That's really cool.
Well, I think that that's pretty
much about all the time
we have left for today.
I want to thank both of you guys
for joining us, Nicole,
for joining us from bright and
sunny LA and Gillian for
joining us from Montreal.
This has been really great, and
I think this experiment
has been fantastic.
You guys both did an absolutely
wonderful job.
It's been amazing to see people
respond to this and
really just sort of react
and love it as well.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Thank you.
PETE LEPAGE: With that, I want
to say thank you for joining
us, and thank you for helping
make this project
a phenomenal success.
NICOLE MCDONALD: Thank you!
GILLIAN FERRABEE: Thanks
for having us.
PETE LEPAGE: Thanks, guys.
All right.